et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous députés de
l'Essonne président de Debout la France
en étant centre pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée ce matin
par Christelle Bertrand du groupe La
Dépêche bonjour Christelle bonjour
Oriane bonjour Nicolas dupontaignan on
va commencer par la question de
l'énergie puisqu'elle Isabelle borde
tiendra une conférence de presse cet
après-midi Nicolas Dupont-Aignan sur ce
sujet elle devrait annoncer des hausse
de tarifs et les contours du nouveau
bouclier tarifaire lundi Bruno Le Maire
a déjà dit je le site il faut que nos
compatriotes absorbent une petite part
de cette hausse vous êtes d'accord avec
ça mais ce sera pas une petite part et
moi je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec
la politique du gouvernement parce que
en vérité il traite pas les causes du
problème et je vais vous donner deux
propositions concrètes parce que
je pense que les Français je l'ai vu cet
été en ont assez des critiques sans des
propositions alternatives ce qu'il
faudrait faire sur l'électricité pour la
France pour éviter les hausses de tarifs
tout simplement c'est retrouver un prix
français l'électricité fondée sur le
prix de notre production électrique et
pas sur le prix du gaz et c'est ça le
seul enjeu et comme Emmanuel Macron ne
veut pas s'autonomiser l'Union
européenne qu'il est le petit
télégraphisme de l'Allemagne il continue
à ruiner les Français il y a un très bon
article aujourd'hui il travaille avec
l'Union européenne pour pour aller vers
ce que vous dites non non la seule
solution c'est un prix national de
l'électricité
autonome comme l’ont fait d'ailleurs le
Portugal et l'Espagne et arrêter
d'aligner notre prix d'électricité sur
celui de l'Allemagne un très bon article
je recommande d'Olivier Marleix pas moi
qui montre que le plan le plan
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est subventionné le
mauvais élève allemand à partir des bons
résultats français c'est aberrant aux
produits notre électricité nucléaire pas
cher on pourrait en faire bénéficier nos
concitoyens et on va subventionner ceux
qui ont sacrifié leur nucléaire
parce que c'est aussi ce que dit le
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que on peut
pas se passer non plus complètement de
la solidarité européenne on a eu un prix
de l'électricité nationale pendant des
dizaines d'années ça n'interdisait pas
de vendre de l'électricité à l'un ou
d'échanger je ne dis pas qu'on va mettre
une ligne Maginot j'ai pas dit ça je dis
que le prix de l'électricité faut le
traiter à la source comme le font les
Espagnols et les Portugais et arrêter de
prendre nos ordres chez Madame
vanderlaen à la Commission de Bruxelles
l'Union européenne dans cette affaire
électrique nous a plantés des
régulations du marché
alignement sur la politique allemande
fermeture de Fessenheim c'est une
hérésie économique
social aujourd'hui traitons la cause des
problèmes au lieu de au lieu d'être dans
cette catastrophe des tarifs et la cause
des problèmes c'est pas le fait qu'on
ait un certain nombre de centrales qui
soient aujourd'hui fermés bien sûr là
c'est pas l'Union européenne
puisqu'on a accepté un plan de
libéralisation qui fait que EDF a
cherché le profit plutôt que l'intérêt
général à long terme deuxièmement c'est
l'Union européenne
c'est l'Allemagne qui a tout fait pour
faire fermer Fessenheim et Emmanuel
Macron a menti droit dans les yeux des
Français il y a 8 jours en disant c'est
pas moi c'est lui en 2018 il s'en
félicitait et c'est pire que ça les
présidents d'EDF l'a dit non non la
décision elle était libre en 2018 et
François Hollande l'a rappelé hier dans
l'interview de libération donc c'est
complètement faux et Emmanuel Macron
ment mais ment comme un arracheur de
dents et pire que ça
il avait la possibilité jusqu'en mars de
cette élection on avait je l'ai dit à la
présidentielle d'arrêter le transfert de
combustible pour rouvrir Fessenheim et
nous permettre de surmonter la crise de
l'hiver donc c'est complètement fou ce
qui se passe ce sont des gens madame
born qui se félicitaient de la fermeture
de Fessenheim et de donner ordre à EDF
de fermer à terme 12 centrales et le
président d'EDF 12 réacteurs très justes
le président de EDF a dit mais nous on
nous a demandé de fermer j'ai pas
recruté des gens pour ouvrir donc ce
sont des gens au pouvoir qui ont menti
aux Français qui ont fait n'importe quoi
et qui maintenant vont demander aux
Français de payer l'addition alors
aujourd'hui comment on fait ces
réacteurs sont à l'arrêt le prix de
l'électricité est celui qui l'est ce
qu'il faut continuer à aider les
Français ou est-ce qu'ils doivent
prendre en effet prendre leur part du
coup alors il faut
séparer le prix de l'électricité du gaz
déjà ça va faire baisser le prix
deuxièmement les centrales sont en
maintenance et il y en a beaucoup qui
vont rouvrir pour l'hiver heureusement
et il faut investir massivement dans
notre électricité nationale il faut
renationaliser et arrêter le marché de
l'électricité libre il faut revenir à un
marché unique français de l'électricité
avec des ventes ou des importations ou
des exportations comme ça se faisait
avant deuxièmement il faut arrêter la
guerre en Ukraine avec l'arrêt des
sanctions il faut arrêter les sanctions
sur la rue totale des sanctions total
des sanctions sur la Russie même
bancaire il faut non du gaz enfin des
sanctions financières fonctions
économique pour être précis économique
vous voyez bien que le conflit en
Ukraine évolue c'est le moment de faire
la paix c'est le moment de faire la paix
c'est le moment pour la France à mon
avis d'avoir une politique indépendante
là aussi l'Union européenne et des
vathan guère qui sont en train de ruiner
le continent car je voudrais insister
sur quelque chose que d'être indépendant
du gaz russe pour vous est-ce qu'il faut
pas devenir indépendant du gaz russe
comme ça on va ruiner l'industrie
européenne vous savez ce qui est en
train de se produire aujourd'hui la
dépendance affectée
ruiner va partir en Chine en Inde aux
États-Unis
la puissance économique européenne est
en train d'être sacrifiée
tout ça pour le don-basse qui est un
pays qui est une zone entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine où les accords de Minsk
avaient permis la paix moi je demande
l'application des accords de mie je ne
suis pas prorus je dis simplement que
ruiner tout un continent créer des
troubles sociaux
sacrifier nos entreprises parce que nos
entreprises sont dans un situation
dramatique elles doivent rembourser le
PGE elles ont les rappels d'URSSAF et
maintenant on leur met la triple peine
avec l'explosion des tarifs ce sont des
centaines de milliers de chômeurs en
plus tout ça pour un conflit où on peut
faire la paix maintenant que la Russie
est affaiblie je dis que c'est le moment
d'arrêter l'assuenchère de proposer un
plan de paix de se mettre autour de la
table et d'essayer de sauver le
continent européen c'est maintenant vous
reconnaissez on est un tournant dans
cette guerre pour vous je pense que
c'est le moment
de tendre la main aux uns et aux autres
et c'est le moment d'arrêter de livrer
des armes c'est le moment où il faut
faire la paix parce que la réalisation
c'est pas aussi ce qui permet aux
Ukrainiens de reprendre du terrain sur
la Russie sur le passé peut-être
maintenant si on veut que le continent
européen soit ruiné au profit de la
Chine et des États-Unis si on veut faire
partir la Russie dans les bras de la
Chine se couper de l'Afrique et avoir
une baisse du niveau de vie de 20% pour
tous les Européens et sacrifier notre
industrie mais on continue comme ça ce
sont des apprentis sorciers je demande
juste que un moment on est un peu de
recul
voilà et je regrette que la France est
perdue son indépendance gaulienne parce
que je peux vous dire si c'était Jacques
Chirac je parle même pas du général de
Gaulle la France serait pas abaissé
comme elle est aujourd'hui avec Emmanuel
Macron on va revenir sur les questions
de sobriété notamment
de se briller énergétique aujourd'hui
qu'en attendez-vous
est-ce que c'est essentiel et bien sûr
c'est toujours bien d'être sobre sur le
plan énergétique et d'ailleurs je vais
vous dire une chose l'hiver dernier
j'étais le seul à en parler il y a 10
millions de Français qui se sont pas
chauffés vous savez ils ont pas besoin
des conseils madame borne ils ont pas
l'argent pour se chauffer et c'est
diverses
non mais ce que j'entends quand
j'entends le gouvernement nous dire faut
éteindre la climatisation il faut
baisser le chauffage mais si il savait
ce que vivent les Français
je veux dire que les Français ils
peuvent même pas payer le chauffage pour
beaucoup d'entre eux donc
tout ça c'est du folklore médiatique
pour amuser les Verts c'est si vous
voulez les économies elles vont se faire
vu le prix exorbitant ce que j'espère
moi ce que je propose c'est que très
vite mais là c'est pas d'attendre des
négociations européennes c'est que la
France reprenne son indépendance de
penser d'action qu'on protège nos
concitoyens qu'on utilise notre atout
nucléaire
qu'on évite la mise au tapis de milliers
d'entreprises justement vous parliez
d'entreprises
pour manifester au côté des entiers
éoliens est-ce qu'on pleine crise
énergétique on peut se passer de
l'énergie des énergies renouvelables
mais oui parce que en fait c'est une
escroquerie gigantesque et j'ai un
chiffre incroyable
on a créé 37 gigawatts d'énergie
renouvelable depuis 10 ans et on est
passé en pilotable c'est-à-dire
thermique et nucléaire de 100 à 87 donc
moins 13 nucléaire thermique plus 37 et
on est en pénurie pourquoi parce que
l'énergie renouvelable est intermittente
et quand il y a pas de vent pendant un
hiver ça ne tourne pas donc on confond
l'énergie installée et l'énergie
produite et je vais vous donner un
exemple Fessenheim
c'est entre 3000 et 5000 éoliennes la
seule centrale de Fessenheim en France
on a 8000 éoliennes 8000 c'est-à-dire
que d'un côté on ferme une centrale et
on nous dit après on va mettre des
éoliennes qui s'arrêtent quand il y a
pas de vent mais ces gens sont devenus
mais non parce que vous ne pouvez pas
quand vous avez une électricité
nucléaire avoir des éoliennes à côté ça
n'a aucun sens on est en train de
défigurer la France on est en train de
payer une fortune ce prix d'électricité
éolien et maintenant ils vont nous
gâcher toutes les façades maritimes
c'est une aberration économique
financière énergétique et tout le monde
Anne ah il faut des éoliennes elles
tournent pas un dernier mot là-dessus
avant de passer à un autre sujet parce
qu'on a beaucoup d'autres sujets est-ce
qu'il y a un débat aussi sur la taxation
des super profits vous êtes favorable à
cette taxation vous je suis favorable à
la taxation de super profit de groupe
français enfin en France sur vraiment
quand il y a un abus
mais je ne suis pas ça ne sera pas la
solution je prends l'exemple voilà quand
ils ont profité mais je ne suis pas
favorable au mécanisme européen qui va
faire en sorte qu'on va subventionner
l'Allemagne avec les bonnes positions
françaises cette absurde
Macron a lancé hier elle convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez c'est une bonne
méthode pour discuter c'est un sujet qui
je pense traverse les opinions
politiques est un sujet de conscience
individuel
côté qui a un débat pourquoi pas moi ce
que j'aimerais c'est qu'on applique déjà
la loi néonetti qui n'est pas appliquée
en France partout et que l'on est
compliquée non elle est très simple la
loi néodétique elle est très simple et
elle vise au contraire justement elle
est très profonde elle est très simple
simplement que ce soit les soins
palliatifs qui sont pas partout que ce
soit les pompes amorphines qui ne sont
pas partout et je pense que le débat est
biaisé parce que on veut passer pour des
raisons idéologiques on l'a bien vu à la
à l'euthanasie il faut être clair ce
gouvernement
mais au lieu d'appliquer la loi néotique
donc déjà moi je pense qu'il faut
appliquer la loi néotique après qu'il y
a un débat pourquoi pas et chacun
s'exprime une convention citoyenne ça
vous paraît bien il faut un débat
uniquement
ça lui fait plaisir qu'il fasse un
référendum sinon vous n'êtes pas un
grand sujet mais vous voyez bien que
c'est un sujet
sont capables de voter en conscience et
je savais Emmanuel Macron fait diversion
le pays est menacé par une crise
économique effrayante des centaines de
milliers de chômeurs une baisse du
revenu des Français de 10 à 20% une
crise de la sécurité et donc il a sorti
ça du chapeau pour qu'on parle d'autre
chose moi je voudrais qu'on parle des
entreprises qui doivent rembourser leur
PGE les PME qui sont en train de faire
faillite je voudrais qu'on parle des
Français qui vont pas se chauffer cet
hiver je voudrais qu'on parle de la
relocalisation d'emploi pour permet de
payer nos retraites Elisabeth burn en
parle aujourd'hui de la crise
énergétique mais pour vous c'est pas un
vrai sujet
il y a pas une vraie demande il y a une
vraie demande pour moi ma position elle
est claire tout le monde la connaitre
Leonetti et je pense que on a pas besoin
de si on vous proposait de voter je
réfléchirai en conscience je n'ai pas
encore le projet de loi j'en sais rien
sur la retraite et l'assurance chômage
sur la retraite
Emmanuel Macron a laissé entendre qu'il
pourrait glisser un projet au sein du
plafss qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
méthode et qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
fond de la réforme Emmanuel Macron est
un pyromane
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était un homme
dangereux qui se nourrit du conflit
qui a mis à feu à sang la France au
premier mandat avec la méthode ou le
fond mais les deux la méthode d'abord
enfin pourquoi cette accélération on a 3
milliards d'excédents en 2022
même le patronat n'en veut personne il y
a un excédent de 3 milliards cette année
3 milliards le rapport du corps a été
complètement biaisé pour faire plaisir
au gouvernement en changeant les données
en changeant les données de productivité
c'est écrit dans toute la presse vous
regardez on a changé les données ils ont
changé les données de départ et de
surcroît même avec ce changement de
données même avec ce changement de
données on arrive à un déficit supposé
supposer entre 7 et 20 milliards ce qui
est le prix des fausses cartes vitales
et on donne 10 milliards à l'Union
européenne en pure perte net donc ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'on est en train
une nouvelle fois le gouvernement
sciemment est en train d'affoler les
Français sur les retraites alors qu'on a
un excédent sans précédent 2022
la réforme des retraites pour que les
retraités français souffrent comme les
autres et je vous le dis
moi je préférerais que le gouvernement
fasse des économies sur les gaspillages
gaspillage 20 milliards sur les fausses
cartes vitales 20 milliards c'est plus
que le déficit imaginé par le corps le
Comité d'Orientation des Retraites
éventuellement en prenant les pires
hypothèses dans 10 ans donc déjà il y a
un gisement de pétrole
engagé là dessus la réforme
il faut avancer là dessus nous donnons
10 milliards net plus de 10 milliards
nets à l'Union européenne en pure perte
10 milliards nous donnons des dizaines
de milliards pour l'immigration et le
président de la République c'est qu'il
aime pas les retraités il les a
massacrés au premier mandat avec la
hausse de CSG le gouvernement dit c'est
la fête et après les avoir baissé
énormément
c'est la faute des retraités mais c'est
honteux
si le faux dans la rue il faudra que les
français si le président de la
République si le président de la
République et le gouvernement je pèse
mes mots il faudra une interruption
nationale et j'attends que tous les
parlementaires votre compte même les LR
même les LR et les LR seront face à leur
responsabilités
et ils seront responsables
d'un traumatisme social soit ils attend
vous êtes parlementaire si la
représentation nationale vote Intex que
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce texte
vous appelez à l'insurrection nationale
on ne peut pas accepter je le pose mes
mots ce n'est pas possible au moment où
la France affronte une crise énergétique
majeure où les Français souffrent ou nos
entreprises sont dans des difficultés
inouïes de recrutement de paiement des
factures d'avoir un président de la
République aussi dingue qui lance un
brûlot pour faire passer une réforme des
retraites à la va-vite alors qu'on a un
système excédentaire je ne comprends pas
je pèse mes mots comment cet homme peut
encore diriger la France qu'est-ce que
vous appelez insérection nationale
Nicolas Dupont si le gouvernement est
assez fou
pour lancer une réforme des retraites
inutile
l'ont souhaité non souhaité autant par
le patronat que par les syndicats je dis
que ce gouvernement a perdu la raison et
qu'il faudra le renverser j'espère que
la motion de censure sera on pourra tout
à fait sur une motion de censure et
j'espère que les Français se
mobiliseront je ne souhaite pas en
arriver là mais je le dis très
clairement président de la République il
devient dangereux pour la France il
devient dangereux pour la
moquait par tous les moyens possibles
mais je préférerais que ce soit par les
parlementaires par la censure et par de
nouvelles élections s'il le faut plutôt
que par la rue je ne souhaite pas la rue
je ne suis pas
révolutionnaire mais je dis qu'il faut
que le Président de la République sage
quand même je dis qu'il faut que le
Président de la République sache que DE
TOUTE j'en appelle rien du tout je dis
que ça finira dans la rue si il passe en
force ça finira dans la rue et il faut à
tout prix au moment où notre pays
affronte tant de difficultés qu'on soit
unie et qu'on essaye de résoudre les
problèmes des entreprises des salariés
plutôt que de mettre la France dans la
rue autre réforme majeure à venir celle
de l'assurance chômage est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à une réduction de la
durée d'indemnisation comme semble le
vouloir le gouvernement j'aimerais déjà
qu'on applique la réforme actuelle voilà
et j'aimerais qu'on fasse un effort sur
les formations j'aimerais qu'on fasse un
effort sur les salaires sur la baisse
des charges car je crois que ce n'est
pas simplement avec le bâton qu'on y
arrivera c'est aussi avec la carotte
alors on peut voir certains ajustements
parce que vous savez qu'il y a une
pénurie de personnel mais je pense que
cette pénurie de personnel n'est pas
seulement liée
aux indemnisations qui ont été réduites
déjà elle est aussi liée un ensemble
d'aides sociales
à une gestion d'aide sociale vous êtes
sur la réduction de certaines
associations je suis pour
une un accroissement de différence entre
la rémunération du travail et la
rémunération de ce qu'on appelle
l'assistana et je pense qu'on peut le
faire plusieurs par exemple je pense que
c'est pas tant le nombre des aides
sociales c'est la manière dont elles
sont données c'est la manière dont cette
organisé et puis c'est la création
d'emplois qu'il faut avoir ce que les
gens ne se font pas par plaisir au
chômage il y a peut-être une minorité
mais dans l'ensemble les gens souffrent
d'être au chômage et donc je n'aime pas
trop la mentalité qui consisterait à
faire croire que tous les Français sont
fainéants c'est pas vrai en revanche les
salaires sont trop faibles en France
l'inflation bouffe les salaires et il
faut absolument
réindexer un peu les salaires il faut
absolument augmenter les salaires si on
veut des salariés une dernière question
un petit mode politique Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de la bataille qui est en train de se
livrer pour la tête des républicains
est-ce que vous avez une préférence
entre les candidats est-ce que est-ce
que selon la personnalité vous aurez
plus de facilité à discuter avec avec
eux ce sont deux personnalités
exceptionnelles voilà
donc je parle de ceux que je connais
bien et donc je pense que ça peut être
une source de renouveau pour LR les deux
est-ce qu'il ne manque pas un peu sur
votre espace politique
moi j'ai un seul souci des passerelles
j'ai un seul souci c'est qu'on sorte la
France de la crise et j'ai un seul souci
c'est qu'on gagne comme en Italie qui
est une vaste union entre le RN debout
la France les LR qu'elle a créé pour
redresser le pays dans l'élection
président
mais je suis convaincu et je sais que
les Français le savent
que l'exemple italien va bousculer la
vie politique française et quand les
Français vont voir les Italiens gagner
ils vont nous dire mais Madame Le Pen
monsieur Zemmour monsieur Dupont-Aignan
monsieur cioti mais arrêtez vos disputes
entendez-vous on repart du bon pied on
redresse le pays on en fait un beau pays
tout est possible donc vous savez que ça
fait longtemps que je le demande dès
2017 merci Nicolas Dupont-Aignan merci
d'avoir été avec nous on regarde la Une
de La Dépêche sujet qui va vous
intéresser faillite la grande peur des
entreprises c'est à la Une de La Dépêche
ce matin merci Christelle et merci
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan on passe au club
des territoires
[Musique]